down meanwhile we have the founder of a
st. Louis chess club Rex Sinquefield
with Maurice Ashley all right yeah we
don't know why they let this guy in the
building but it is Rex Sinquefield
indeed the founder of the club and one
of the visionaries behind the
Grantchester and all the great things
that happens here Rex welcome once again
to the show thank you I know this is
your favorite time if your office didn't
st. Louis
it is absolutely as I mean how crazy
August can be the hottest month but it's
great it was great today I was out on
the track running todayõs pretty good
and I didn't get arrested for speeding
or anything you know but yeah this is
the crown jewel I think of a grand
Chester and it's certainly the crown
jewel of the year here in st. Louis
especially with all the people come
around the kids the fans it's just
wonderful you get to hang out and tell
stories are the best players in the
world that's right I'll get to talk to
em VL and LaVon about their draw but you
know I understand why it was a draw
there coming off of two rest days you
know we like to see them fight but that
was a tricky one even for the top
players we saw your wife we had your
wife on earlier today and she was
talking about all the great activities
she's doing as well you must be really
proud of all this chest that's
constantly abuzz here yeah she's
incredible she's young she's not doing
just a lot in chess was she doing an
amazing amount with Boy Scouts not just
the 250,000 chess merit badges but the
invention lab that she's come up with I
mean it's really incredible two big
complex down by the Lake of the Ozarks
and different scouting troops from
around the country will come to visit
how do you see this tournament getting
bigger we're gonna see next year maybe
another couple hundred thousand gonna
toss on there I wanted to pay a lot more
of it you I said no you know sorry joy
that's it that's you know to be crass
that's the way to do it and I think I
have been thinking seriously we need to
augment these prizes a little bit each
year especially on the women's events I
think they're too far behind the events
that the men are playing in
the Grantchester itself has expanded and
we're gonna see Romania show come into
the picture we're gonna see India come
into the picture any thought to more
places or you know I would defer to
garry kasparov on that one he's been not
just the great thinker on this but he's
been the source of the context he knows
these people all over the world as you
know and so he's really helped arrange
some of these things and I would defer
to him if he says we got to have one
more in place X Y Z you know what's
happened in Greenland I just heard the
United States is thinking of buying
Greenland you know I don't think the
chess players are going to want to go to
Greece there's always green and
Greenland there's always under ice the
the plate you're talking also about
judges these events but all year you
have event C I mean all year every when
I go into Toni Rich's office Sony which
the executive director and I look at his
big board I know I mean it's dizzying
it's like you see every month
they're so major event going on yeah it
is it's been it's really wonderful and
it's because of the great staff Toni and
joy and all the other people that helped
them that were able to handle all of
these events and we're getting
cooperation from throughout the city and
of course it's very helpful that other
universities have started
scholarship based teams like st. Louis
University and now the University of
Missouri that just brings more Grand
Master's into the state makes it easier
for us to have visiting Grand Master's
like right now our Grand Master in
residence is Dorsett Derek Shani from
the st. Louis University chess team so
it's it's really wonderful like I I will
assert but I don't know this as
effectually that they're probably more
grandmasters in st. Louis now than there
are in Moscow right now you know you
always make up some facts I did I do we
never know what you're saying is right
well fact check that one that's okay but
there's no doubt that there are a number
of kids programs that are going on there
very much you mentioned and we usually
just see the bright eyes of these
youngsters as they get into the game you
see them here at the club playing a lot
of chess maybe some the fact that they
can play chess here at the club on those
sweet chess boards there
maybe not your latest chess set by Nate
Cohen
but these are just incredible to see the
kids from the community come and play
and feel like they're being treated like
stars yeah they really are being treated
like stars and they deserve it these
kids work hard they study they learn you
can learn things from books I think
that's one of the great things about
chess and helping their cognitive
development and my favorite kid program
everybody knows this is the cops and
kids in chess we teach the st. Louis
police officers how to teach chess they
go into the inner city public schools
and they play chess and teach chess with
these kids and I just had lunch last
week with Judge Jimmy Edwards and police
chief Hayden and they both want to see
that program accelerated which is music
to my ears
and in fact what we want to do if I can
let the cat out of the bag is they would
like to see the equivalent of a police
team against the fire team against the
FBI against the DEA we have something
here in st. Louis called the guns and
hoses which is a boxing match between
the police department and the fire
department with headgear protection etc
but it's designed to raise money for
back stoppers and they said we could do
the same thing raise money for back
stoppers and I think the st. Louis
community would respond to it well
that's a wonderful bit of news breakdown
news by Rex Sinquefield it's all that
happens thanks so much for everything
that you do rest thank you very thanks
to you and your Alice and Jennifer
incredibly best broadcast in the entire
galaxy